>>> WNBA SR BRITTENY GRINER IS
BEING DETAINED IN MOSCOW AS
TENSNS RATCHET UP BETWEEN
MOOW AND THE U.S. OVER THE
INVASION OF UKRAINE.
GRINER WAS ARRESTED ON DRUG
CHARGES A MONTH AGO BUT THE NEWS
ONLY MADE PUBLIC A WEEK AGO.
THEY DETECTED CANNABIS OIL IN
HUR
HER LUGGAGE.
U.S. OFFICIALS ARE WORKING TO
BRING HER HOME.
>> Reporter: AS THE DEMOCRATIC
TIES BETWEEN THE U.S. AND RUSSIA
CRUMBLE, A WNBA STAR IS CAUGHT
IN THE MIDDLE.
PHOENIX MERCURY CENTER BRITTENY
GRINER WAS ARRESTED ON DRUG
CHARGES AFTER RUSSIAN CUSTOMS
OFFICIALS SAID THEY FOUND VAPE
CARTRIDGES THAT CONTAINED
CANNABIS OIL IN HER LUGGAGE AT
AN AIRPORT NEAR MOSCOW IN
FEBRUARY.
GRINER REMAINS IN CUSTODY.
>> I'VE TALKED TO A COUPLE
SOURCES, AND THEY SAID IT'S BEEN
A COUPLE OF WEEKS THAT THIS HAS
BEEN GOING ON.
ONE SOURCE SAID SINCE THE NBA
ALL STAR GAME.
>> Reporter: SECRETARY OF STATE
ANTONY BLINKEN GAVE FEW
SPECIFICS ON GRINER'S CASE.
>> WHENEVER AN AMERICAN IS
DETAINED ANYWHERE IN THE WORLD,
WE OF COURSE STAND READY TO
PROVIDE EVERY POSSIBLE
ASSISTANCE, AND THAT INCLUDES IN
RUSSIA.
>> Reporter: THE EPISODE COMES
AS THE UNITED STATES HAS
IMPLEMENTED ECONOMIC SANCTIONS
ON RUSSIA AS ITS ASSAULT ON
UKRAINE INTENSIFIES.
>> WHAT DOES THE TIMING OF THE
DETENTION TELL YOU?
>> I THINK IT TELLS YOU
EVERYTHING.
THE TRAJECTORY OF THE CASE NOW
WILL PROBABLY BE DIFFERENT, AND
SO THEY WILL DEFINITELY LOOK FOR
SORT OF A CERTAIN BARGAINING
CHIP EFFECT, PROPAGANDA EFFECT.
>> GIVEN THE TIMING OF THIS,
DOES THE U.S. HAVE LIMITED
LEVERAGE GIVEN WHAT'S GOING ON
IN UKRAINE?
>> OH, FOR SURE.
PRESIDENT PUTIN HAS DECLARED
THAT THE WEST IS AT WAR WITH HIM
BY LEVYING THESE ECONOMIC
SANCTIONS.
HE HAS LIKENED THEM TO WAR, AND
SO JUST BEING AN AMERICAN
CITIZEN WHO CAN POTENTIALLY BE
ACCUSED OF CARRYING A SUBSTANCE
SHE WAS NOT SUPPOSED TO BE
CARRYING, OF COURSE WHETHER THAT
ACTUALLY CORRESPONDS TO THE
FACTS WE DON'T EVEN KNOW, AND I
WOULDN'T PUT ANYTHING BEYOND THE
AUTHORITIES THERE, SO YEAH, THIS
IS PROBABLY A PROPAGANDA TRICK.
>> CONGRESSWOMAN SHEILA JACKSON
LEE WHO REPRESENTS GRINER'S HOME
CITY OF HOUSTON CALLING FOR HER
RELEASE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO DISREGARD A
SOVEREIGN NATION, BUT PUTIN HAS
DISREGARDED SOVEREIGN NATIONS
HIS ENTIRE SERVICE IN THIS
WORLD, AND ANYONE THAT IS
KILLING AND ATTACKING AND
DESTROYING UKRAINE, THEIR
NEIGHBORING COUNTRY THAT HAS NOT
BOTHERED THEM, HAS NO RIGHT TO
HOLD MS. GRINER, PERIOD.
>> AND GRINER'S WIFE BREAKING
HER SILENCE IN AN INSTAGRAM POST
THANKING EVERYONE FOR THEIR
SUPPORT AND WRITING, QUOTE,
PLEASE HONOR OUR PRIVACY AS WE
CONTINUE TO WORK ON GETTING MY
WIFE HOME SAFELY.
BACK HOME IN HOUSTON, GRINER'S
HIGH SCHOOL COACH GREW EMOTIONAL
WORRIED GRINER COULD FACE SEVERE
CONSEQUENCES.
>> WHAT'S YOUR BIGGEST FEAR?
>> MY BIGGEST FEAR IS THAT THIS
WILL BECOME -- THAT SHE'LL BE A
POLITICAL PAWN.
>> IF SHE BY ANY CHANCE WATCHES
THIS STORY, WHAT WOULD YOU TELL
HER?
>> I WOULD TELL HER PLEASE KNOW
THAT YOU ARE LOVED BY SO MANY
PEOPLE.
YOU'VE ALWAYS HAD A TRUE RESOLVE
AND GRIT TO GET TO THE FINISH
LINE AND KNOW THAT IT'S -- YOU
WILL GET TO THE FINISH LINE THIS
TRIAL YOU'RE GOING THROUGH, THIS
ORDEAL.
>> Reporter: THE WNBA TELLING
CNN THAT ALL OF THE ATHLETES
THAT WERE COMPETING IN RUSSIA
AND UKRAINE HAVE EXITED THOSE
COUNTRIES EXCEPT FOR KBGRINER.
THE U.S. DEPARTMENT OF STATE
ISSUING A DO NOT TRAVEL ADVISORY
FOR RUSSIA AND THE REASONS
LISTED ARE VERY TELLING.
IT OF COURSE INCLUDES RUSSIA'S
INVASION OF UKRAINE, BUT IT ALSO
SAYS THAT OFFICIALS THERE,
GOVERNMENT OFFICIALS COULD
HARASS U.S. CITIZENS, THAT THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT RIGHT NOW HAS
LIMITED ABILITY TO HELP U.S.
CITIZENS IN RUSSIA.
AND ALSO, THAT RUSSIANS -- THAT
U.S. CITIZENS WHO ARE IN RUSSIA,
COULD SEE THE ARBITRARY
ENFORCEMENT OF THE LAW THERE,
ERICA, AND OF COURSE RIGHT NOW
THE FOCUS FOR THE FRIENDS AND
FAMILY OF BRITTENY GRINER IS TO
RETURN HER TO THE UNITED STATES.
ERICA.
>> ABSOLUTELY, AND TO GET SOME
ANSWERS.
ROSA FLORES, APPRECIATE IT,
THANK YOU.
JOINING US NOW, KIMBERLY ST.
JULIAN, A DOCTORAL STUDENT IN
HISTORY AT THE UNIVERSITY OF
PENNSYLVANIA WHO ANALYZES RACE,
FOREIGN POLICY, AND CULTURE IN
RUSSIA AND UKRAINE.
IT'S GREAT TO HAVE YOU WITH US
THIS MORNING BECAUSE I THINK
YOUR EXPERTISE CAN REALLY HELP
US UNDERSTAND WHERE WE MAY BE
AND WHERE BRITTANY FWRIENER MAY
BE AT THIS MORNING.
CONGRESSMAN JOHN GARAMENDI WAS
ON EARLIER HERE ON CNN, AND SAID
IT'S GOING TO BE, QUOTE, VERY
DIFFICULT TO GET HER RELEASED,
AND HE ALSO BROUGHT UP RUSSIA'S
ANTI-LGBTQ LAWS, AND HE SAYS
THESE COULD ALSO COME INTO PLAY.
I SEE YOU NODDING YOUR HEAD.
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU AGREE?
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
JUST BEYOND THE FACT THAT SHE IS
A VERY HIGH PROFILE AMERICAN
ATHLETE, THE FACT THAT SHE IS A
VISIBLE MINORITY, A BLACK WOMAN
BUT ALSO SHE IS OPENLY GAY AND A
MEMBER OF THE LGBTQ COMMUNITY,
NONE OF THESE BODE WELL FOR HER
IN RUSSIAN CUSTODY.
BUT ALSO, WE HAVE TO BE WORRIED
THAT ANY OF THE LISTS OF
ANTI-LGBTQ LAWS ON THE BOOKS IN
RUSSIA COULD ALSO BE LEVIED
AGAINST HER.
>> WHEN WE LOOK AT WHAT WE KNOW,
AND IT'S NOT A LOT QUITE FRANKLY
AT THIS MOMENT, THE FACT THAT
THIS ARREST ACTUALLY HAPPENED
LAST MONTH, WE ARE SEEING THESE
STATEMENTS.
ROSA JUST HIGHLIGHTED THE
STATEMENT FROM BRITTENY GRINER'S
WIFE APPRECIATING EVERYONE'S
SUPPORT BUT ASKING THAT THEIR
PRIVACY IS RESPECTED AT THIS
TIME.
HOW DO YOU THINK THAT HAS ALSO
SHIFTED SINCE RUSSIA INVADED
UKRAINE?
>> I THINK HER FAMILY'S RESPONSE
IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT AND ALSO
THE BEST WAY TO HANDLE THIS
BECAUSE THE -- WE DON'T KNOW
WHAT SPECIFIC DAY IN FEBRUARY
GRINER WAS ARRESTED.
WE JUST KNOW IT HAPPENED IN
FEBRUARY.
SO I THINK THE FACT THAT WE'VE
SEEN THIS ESCALATION, THE
DECLARATION OF WAR IN UKRAINE
AND THE AMERICAN, YOU KNOW,
RESPONSE TO THAT, ALL OF THESE
CAN EXACERBATE HER CASE, BUT AS
SECRETARY BLINKEN SAID, WE
ALREADY HAVE -- THE UNITED
STATES HAS LIMITED AMBASSADORIAL
AND ALSO CONSULATE ABILITIES IN
RUSSIA RIGHT NOW.
SO I THINK THE THINGS THAT
AREN'T BEING SAID ARE IMPORTANT.
WE DON'T KNOW HOW LONG SHE'S
BEEN KEPT.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE SHE IS.
WE JUST KNOW THAT SHE'S IN
RUSSIAN CUSTODY.
SO I THINK BEING CAREFUL WITH
HOW WE SPECULATE ABOUT THIS IS
VERY IMPORTANT BECAUSE ALL OF
THIS COULD INFLUENCE HER CASE.
>> SECRETARY BLINKEN SAID THE
U.S. IS ALWAYS WORKING TO GET
AMERICANS OUT OF RUSSIAN
PRISONS.
SHE'S NOT ALONE.
HER HIGH SCHOOL COACH SAID SHE'S
WORRIED THAT BRITTENY GRINER
COULD BECOME A POLITICAL PAWN,
BUT SHE'S NOT THE ONLY AMERICAN.
HOW DOES ALL OF THAT WEIGH IN
THESE NEGOTIATIONS?
>> I THINK THIS IS IMPORTANT.
SHE IS NOT THE ONLY AMERICAN
WHO'S BEEN IN RUSSIAN CUSTODY.
TWO HIGH PROFILE CASES, PAUL
WEILAND, AND TREVOR REED, BOTH
OF THESE ARE AMERICANS, BOTH ARE
FORMER MARINES AND THEY ARE
CURRENTLY SERVING LONG PRISON
SENTENCES IN RUSSIA DUE TO THESE
TRUMPED UP CHARGES.
THE THREAT IS VERY REAL THAT
B
BRITTNEY COULD BE FACING A LONG
TIME IN PRISON IN RUSSIA, BUT
ALSO NO MATTER WHAT THE UNITED
STATES COULD DO, THIS IS STILL
UP TO RUSSIAN COURTS AND RUSSIAN
JURIES TO DECIDE WHAT WILL
HAPPEN TO HER.
THIS IS A VERY DELICATE
SITUATION, AND WE HAVE BEEN
WORKING ON THE TREVOR REED AND
PAUL WEILAND CASE FOR YEARS NOW,
BUT THESE TWO